schon wieder blockieren umweltschützer
mit einer abseilaktion einer autobahn
dieses mal die a 3 bei idstein in hessen
seit dem frühen morgen bereiteten drei
aktivisten die aktion an einer
fußgängerbrücke vor leitspruch dadurch
dass wir hängen erzeugen wir einen
künstlichen stau und aufmerksamkeit die
umweltschützer sind gegner des
umstrittenen a49 ausbaus und setzen sich
somit für den schutz des dauerfrostes 1
die autobahnpolizei musste die a 3
frankfurt-köln zwischen dem wiesbadener
kreuz und niedernhausen in beiden
richtungen voll sparen dass solche
aktionen menschenleben aufs spiel setzen
können zeigte sich vor zwei wochen am 13
oktober erzeugten die aktivisten durch
ihre abseilaktion einen stau in dem es
zu einem schweren unfall kam ein 29
jähriger skoda fahrer knallte am
stauende in einen laster er musste
zeitweise ins künstliche koma versetzt
werden die umweltaktivisten haben sich
von diesem unfall offenbar nicht
abschrecken lassen denn auch heute
morgen verursachten sie durch ihre
aktion einen riesenstau mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bild schaut
euch hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren